le viagra en 1991 un labo lance une
étude clinique sur une molécule le
citrate de syldenafil qu'ils ont mis au
point pour traiter un certain type de
maladies cardiaques qu'on appelle
l'angor ou encore angine de poitrine
comme souvent dans ces cas-là on donne à
un groupe de patients le médicament et
aux autres un placebo on se rend compte
que ça marche pas très bien ça marche
pas très bien sur le cœur en tout cas
l'étude est arrêtée et au moment de
rendre les comprimés il y a un certain
nombre de patients qui traînent un peu
les pieds l'histoire an serait resté là
si personne n'avait cherché à comprendre
pourquoi et il s'est avéré que les
petits malins avaient remarqué que le
Viagra ne faisait pas grand chose à leur
cœur c'est vrai mais qu'il avait un
effet bénéfique sur un autre organe
quelques ajustements dans le médicament
et cette année plus tard le Viagra
obtient son autorisation de mise sur le
marché en 1998 pour le labo c'est le
jackpot avec plusieurs milliards de
dollars de vente
pas mal pour un essai raté quand même